- Welcome back.
We are here with the stars
of the new movie, Air,
which is in theaters
starting starting April 5th.
First of all,
congratulations, Ben, on Air.
It is an incredible story
and it's interesting.
I knew nothing about
Michael Jordan's start.
I knew nothing about the
company- I knew nothing.
And it is so informative
and funny and serious
and has real issues that you talk about,
as far as knowing your worth.
- Well, that's interesting
'cause there are people who,
like definitely are kind of
not into sports or basketball
- That's like me, yeah.
- or sports movies or that kind of thing.
Who are like, "See that's not my thing".
But actually it's not that, it's really,
it's not a rah-rah thing.
It's not about like you
have to know the sport
and the locker room
and we're gonna win it.
It's about how this person, you know,
Michael Jordan, meant so much to the world
and represented something
so big and so amazing.
He kind of changed the way
the world perceived athletes
and the way they connected
Nike, in concert with him,
kind of, it was the first
time you associated a product,
a brand-
- Yeah.
- [Ben] With a person and their identity.
Back then they were in the
cellar with basketball shoes.
Converse was killing.
Adidas was the cool shoes.
- I didn't know all that.
- [Chris, Matt, and Ben] Yeah.
- I know.
- That was the weird thing,
reading the script was what-
I mean I just thought it
was such a great story
that I didn't know.
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- And kinda at the beginning
of the movie did have to
re-contextualize that time, 'cause you go,
we all live in the world
post Michael Jordan,
post Air Jordan you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- [Matt] So to take us
back to that time right
before it all happened and
what the world looked like,
and it's funny to think of Nike
as an underdog 'cause they're so-
- That's what I'm saying!
And then knowing Adidas,
like, it was just-
it was an interesting thing
that I did not know about.
Even how- I loved when you and
Viola Davis' character were
at her house and you were just going back
and forth about like what
to expect in those meetings.
- (laughing) Right. Right.
- [Kelly] They like play it out.
Like it was brilliant and it was funny,
but it was really honest as well.
And it really showed how the
company really got behind-
I mean y'all literally
sank everything into like-
they sank everything into this one person.
= Well, it seems like
an obvious thing now.
- [Kelly] But not then.
- But it was a real-
it was a massive gamble that they-
- What I loved about it is,
as you mentioned, Viola-
is that you think it's really-
well it's gonna be this
guy's Sonny's story,
or it's gonna be Michael Jordan's story.
And you get halfway through the movie,
which sort of mirrored the process I had
in exploring it and trying
to put together the cast
and the whole sort of ideas
that were important to me.
And you find out really like
almost like I was almost embarrassed
that it wasn't obvious to begin with.
That without Deloris Jordan, his mother-
- Yeah.
- [Ben] Really guiding him and helping him
and making us do- none
of that would happen.
And it just makes so much sense.
Like all these moms, like
I think of my own mom.
My mom loves all my movies,
you know what I mean?
She thinks everything's great.
I'm like, they're not all great, mom.
But you know? God bless her.
And nobody loves you like your mother.
And the way that, especially young people
and the case of the NBA and entertainment,
you see, they get thrust
into these positions.
Sometimes they're from
marginalized communities,
they've historically
been taken advantage of,
and here they are with
these opportunities,
they're supposed to be negotiating
with these massive companies.
It's a whole, you know,
we know a little bit about
sort of stepping from one world
into another- it's a lot.
And if you don't have that
person there to anchor you
and guide you might be in trouble.
- And also though what you're saying is,
seems a bit normalized now.
People do fight for that now.
But back then, like
even on the phone call,
you were like, oh ma'am you
don't know how this works.
Like, that's not how it works.
And she was basically like,
"But this is how it's
going to, if you'd like
to work with my-" and I
thought that was so powerful.
- Because it's important
to understand the people
that said, "No, there's a
difference between a salary
and a fee, and ownership.
- Yeah.
- And people, owners-
In other words, you go out
and you create the value
in the shoe by being Michael Jordan.
Well, you're an owner of your identity
and you should own what
that means to this company.
It's not like, "Yeah, well
we get to pay your fee"
and "Oh! Good for us!".
We make billions of dollars
and you make your fee.
- Yeah.
I will say one of my favorite parts too,
and I think that this gets lost sometimes.
Everybody knows at this point,
Michael Jordan is Michael Jordan.
He is the greatest. Right?
So like everybody knows that.
So, but the the point is,
is that everybody doesn't know the people
behind the scenes that
made that whole brand,
that made all of that
Nike, everything come like-
that's powerful.
- By the way, Michael
Jordan's not in the movie
on purpose.
- I love that by the way!
- I just thought, if you show
somebody, you try to pretend,
you tell them, this is Michael Jordan-
because he's so iconic and means so much,
immediately you know it's a lie.
Immediately the movie fall apart.
And what's more interesting
is that the way our heroes,
these gods, kind of
operate in our lives is not
in our day-to-day lives, but we see them.
You see him on footage in game films.
But you know, they're not in real life.
They're larger than life.
And the audience brings their
imagination and memory to it.
And it's, you know, I do really think
it's my favorite movie I've ever made.
Viola Davis is amazing, Julius Tennon,
Jason Bateman, Chris Tucker.
- [Kelly] The cast is incredible!
- These are brilliant-
they did a great job.
I just watched- I'm so proud of it.
It really is fun.
- [Kelly] The writing is incredible.
- It really should be seen in a theater.
It's a lot of fun in a theater.
April 5th, check it out.
- It's so good. I literally
have told everyone-
I literally went to a show,
I did this show last night
and I walked in and like,
now my eyes go to Jordans.
And so I'm like, and I
walked in, I was like,
"Oh my God, you're gonna love the movie."
I'm like your street team.
I'm like, everywhere I go, like literally.
And then I had conversations
with everybody about this movie
and I'm like, they're like,
"Okay, should I see it?"
I was like, you should 100% see it!
I was like, it's so good!
- The beginning of shoe culture.
- I know!
- This is the very first time.
- That's a whole thing too, yeah.
It like- it ignited this whole-
my closet is mainly
sneakers. Like I love it.
Like I think a lot of us are like that.